Derek starts off this hour in Louisville
Kentucky
hi Derek how are you good Dave and you
better than I deserve what's up
well me and my wife have accumulated
quite a bit of debt over the years and
we've got your where we've had your
Financial Peace University for a little
while you know just kind of need a
little bit of guidance to let us know
that the light is at the end of the
tunnel okay how much debt do you have
not counting your home a hundred and
forty thousand mm-hmm what's that on
what kind of doing everything credit
cards a few hospital bills some other
awesome stuff we got a car loan well how
much is the car loan the car loan twenty
one thousand okay is there what are the
what's the big amount of the 140 student
loans credit cards our house is the big
one when I said I'm not Canadian your
house not counting your house you said
you had 140 not counting the house yet
student loans okay how much are your
student loans almost 40,000 okay the 40
and the car and the student loans is
only sixty at least eighty thousand
dollars what's that other eighty all
credit cards a lot of them are and we
got a wedding vitro so that was a little
bit of it is that sharking are for loans
with that is that charged on a credit
card we had to have some help when we
done it yeah I'm saying you had in vitro
I got that did you charge that on a
credit card
no we person along to a bank on secure
long to a bank and how much was that
loan I mean we had to do it twice of one
is a looking for here once about 7200
and the other one is around 10,000 okay
so I'm still hearing something like 50
or $60,000 in credit card
what's your household income me my wife
together make 140 thousand we made last
year before taxes
good okay and what have you done to get
out of debt so far I wrote everything
down and we have started a step one and
uh and we're trying to but like you say
we're inr minimums and we're trying to
get our step one saved up so we start
snowball mm-hmm okay
so have the two of you actually been
through the Financial Peace University
class or you just bought it we went
through it with the church and then life
happens and we missed a day or two and
we just never got to get back into it
mm-hmm because here's what you've got
you you have a huge mess
yes there you guys ought to be pretty
scared if you're not you're not wise you
should this should scare the crud out of
you it's a scary set of math you've
given me and the Pat the habit patterns
that brought us into this math or even
more scary and how long have y'all been
married in years that's what I was going
to say ten or twelve yeah yeah you've
made a unbelievable mess here so the two
of you together are both going to have
to get scared enough that you get mad
enough that you get blinders on and you
don't think about anything else about
what we can cut out of our life so we
can throw it at this debt because here's
the thing if you'll if you cut your
lifestyle down to nothing I mean nothing
you have no life let's say you threw
seventy thousand out of your hundred and
forty thousand dollar income at the debt
that would put you debt-free in two
years but that's that's got you living
with nothing I mean there's nothing
nothing nothing nothing okay and beans
and rice rice and beans and you're
selling stuff and everything else and
you're going crazy here how many kids
have you all got we have a
fourteen-year-old in a set of two year
old twins okay
the 14 year olds going to be miserable
because we're got nothing because this
is a
mess and so what I would tell the two of
you to do is to go back through
Financial Peace University this time get
your I'm serious about this I'm mad
about this I'm not living like this
anymore eyes on you get that settle lens
on you can work through this but you're
going to have to become so obsessed and
so focused on this subject with a
written budget go to every dollar calm
and get on your written budget and you
know it's a free budgeting tool that we
give you a free budgeting app for your
iPhone or your Android and get that
thing started and you've already paid
for Financial Peace University go back
through it again it's free to go back
through it and we want to make sure you
get some help but you're going to have
to get very very very very focused and
serious or this is going to drag out and
you're going to hit a speed bump at some
point in the door the wheels are going
to come off this thing you're gonna have
a mess a real mess you got a mess now I
mean you're going to you're being a
crisis you may not be able to recover
from if you hit the hit the wrong speed
bump along the way so I get the pressure
off of this I'm not sure I would keep
this car but if you start making huge
progress on the car on the rest of that
you want we really really want to keep
the car that's fine but get those credit
cards out tonight and cut every single
one of them up no exceptions and no you
can't do cutesy crap and put them in the
freezer you have got to take some very
serious and purposeful steps if you do
you can turn this around hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]